[Music]
weaving through the capital a picture of
urgency the coronavirus coupled with
winter
makes for a cocktail of mounting
infections
london and the southeast of england are
feeling the strain
with the capital's ambulance service
receiving 8
000 calls on boxing day it was one of
their busiest days
ever paramedic richard is on the front
line
i think there's there's three factors
really one is there's a number of staff
who are off sick
either with covid or isolating as a
result of family members who've got
covered
we're seeing an increase in workload
because of patients with covid
or with difficulty breathing and the
ambulance crews are often spending
several hours at hospital
waiting to offload their patients which
means there are less ambulances
available
so we see a number of calls waiting and
certainly i've experienced
patients waiting several hours for an
ambulance currently
medics at queen's hospital in east
london speak of treating patients in the
back of ambulances
we spoke to one doctor who told us that
all beds were full
and they were running a one-in-one out
operation
[Music]
ambulances in and out of st thomas's
hospital also reinforced the stresses
of those on the wards it's very tough
we've had a combination
of you have this increased demand
ambulances keep coming in
we are desperate to offload ambulances
that's always been a priority for us
because we know that you know an
ambulance needs to be available to go
and see
the next person who's in a car accident
or um who's
uh having a heart attack i mean they
need to be available to go
and you feel terrible when you have a
sense of helplessness when you can't
offload an ambulance because your
emergency department is full
there are 4 000 people in london
hospitals
being treated for covid19 nationally the
number of people
in hospital with the virus is thought to
be nearly as many as during the peak
of the first wave it's thought the new
variant is to blame
public health england have tonight made
a rare intervention
their medical director said this very
high level of infection
is of growing concern at a time when our
hospitals are at their most vulnerable
with new admissions rising in many
regions
we've all made huge sacrifices this year
but we must all continue to play our
part
in stopping the spread of the virus
which is still replicating fast
the vaccine remains the ray of hope with
news the oxford astrazeneca jab
could be approved by the regulator in
the coming days
winter carries its own pile of pressure
with respiratory viruses
favoring colder climates
a worry on the mind of those in the
capital clambering to contain the spread
ashna harinak sky news